bonsoir président pour la première fois
il ya un truc
la nouvelle émission d'armand jammu et
jacques gérard cornu avec le concours de
gérard majax francfort gérard qui tous
les soirs va mettre à l'épreuve votre
imagination et votre perspicacité que
les bras gérard comme lui vous pourrez
faire des trucs avec je pense pas grand
chose au nom ce sont de petits trucs de
femme repart avec des allumettes des
sucres des petites cuillers enfin tout
ce qu'on trouve chez soi alors petits et
grands vous pouvez le faire et je vous
signale que nous avons su de très très
nombreuses lettres venant d'un peu
partout de paris et de la france entière
et que parmi ces lettres dieu nous avons
choisi quelques candidats je veux
d'ailleurs vous les présenter ses
candidats qui ont été tirés au sort
avant l'émission de façon à ce qu'ils
aient chacun un numéro et bien tout de
suite notre candidate numéro un
mademoiselle elle mélanie francine de
sonore très bien candidat numéro 2
gilles romillé de vernir aux candidates
numéro trois un tarif à l'eau de paris
8ème ces six candidats numéro 4 chaque
mois ou clos marc candidat numéro 5
andré de repos bagneux quand il paraît
bien fort s'il vous plaît candidat
numéro 6 josette au goût d'or de mou et
bien vous regardez bien votre récepteur
de télévision qui se trouve en face de
vous et tout de suite notre truc
démarrent les allumettes magnétique
vous avez certainement chez vous des
allumettes bien prenons trois allumettes
et regardez bien une propriétés
magnétiques peu connue des allumettes
il suffit de frotter l'extrémité d'une
allumette contre de la laine et là ça ne
peut pas rater les deux autres allaient
mettre sont repoussés voilà
vous avez les allumettes vous pouvez
essayer mais si vous ne réussissez pas
ce qu'il vous manque une seule chose un
tout petit détail le truc car croyez moi
il ya un truc
et oui il ya un truc et ce truc qu'il
faut le trouver bien sûr je signale au
candidat que notre premier truc vaut 300
francs notre première candidate a sans
doute des questions à poser à gérard
majax à mademoiselle l'ami de sa mort
oui est ce que le fait de se frotter sur
votre votre veste en laine apporte une
certain certains une certaine etc
tricité quelque chose à vous avez bien
étudié la physique à l'école ah oui oui
oui oui vous savez que lorsqu on frotte
un objet on obtient une certaine
électricité statique en général c'est
vrai mais pour ce petit truc ça ne sert
strictement à rien je suis navré
mademoiselle je regrette beaucoup
nous faisons tout de suite à notre
candidat numéro deux mesures et blier
est-ce que vous utilisez un autre
ustensile pour ce truc a alors commencé
à vous méfiez vous savez que dans les
petits trucs de traditions populaires on
peut rajouter un petit ustensile secret
enfin ustensiles un petit objet en plus
petit objet en oui et bien là je crois
que vous avez raison on se sert de
quelque chose en plus si vous avez une
solution vous nous n'a donné tout de
suite
est ce que ce serait quelque chose qui
ferait ressort à qui serait pouvoir en
plastique
ah oui oui je crois que vous êtes sur la
bonne voie vous n'avez pas une précision
plus grande
28 oh de plastique un petit tuyau de
plastique et bien écoutez venez près de
moi je crois que vous avez
voilà des allumettes venait de ce côté
venez par là que tout le monde nos amis
téléspectateurs vous vois bien et je
vais vous prêter des allumettes beaucoup
plus gros soyez qui sont là avec un
petit tuyau de plastique
vous savez on met du pain ce regard des
déplacés sur le bout d'une main de
maître montre et de nous y voilà on met
ici lundi c'est la deuxième a dit m
tenez vous même les deux mains gauches
pour la plier montrait bien nos amis
téléspectateurs voilà où se trouve le
petit tubes classiques serré entre les
doigts et tenez le bien prenez notre
allait m'être fait semblant de le
frotter voilà et maintenant vous dites à
vos amis regardez ça s'écarte
effectivement elle ses cadres vous avez
compris oui ça fait rire nos amis bravo
avons comparé à notre jeu suivant venir
va vous poser une ou deux questions jeu
d'où venez vous vous êtes vous habitez
loin de paris je crois que oui ça 150
km/h et vous êtes venus pour jouer avec
nous oui mais dit-on ça tombe bien que
vous ayez gagné à nancy loin alors c'est
normal une émission très sympathique
vous permettre un déplacement et bien
savez monsieur vous avez gagné 300
francs je vous en prie regagner votre
place mais pour le deuxième trou que
vous ne jouez pas bon monsieur régulier
de vernir aux bravo bravo et nous allons
passer si vous le voulez bien tout de
suite à notre deuxième truc
regardez bien vous récepteur vous êtes
prêts le génie de la bouteille d'eau
avec une paille et une bouteille de
bière on rentre la paille dans la
bouteille de bière et maintenant le
problème c'est d'essayer d'essayer par
un simple petit geste magique de
soulever la bouteille avec la paille
c'est possible mais pas grâce à un petit
génie qui est dans la bouteille
simplement un tout petit truc âge est
bien le premier truc ayant été trouvé
c'est le numéro 2 qu'il a trouvé le je
veux que nous passions tout de suite aux
candidats à la candidate numéro 3
mademoiselle avez vous une question à
poser à gérardmer
acx non je préfère passer ma part un don
vous préférez passer la parole à
l'écouté alors là vous me fait mal au
coeur je suis sûr que vous avez une
petite question à poser sur ce tour
réfléchissez rien je vais vous dire un
secret il n'y a pas de génie dans la
bouteille ça déjà vous saviez vous
voulez vous réservez vous ne voulez pas
posé de questions je pense que vous
utilisez un autre instant si rossi qui a
peut-être qui je ne vois pas quel et je
préfère et bien non je réponds quand
même à votre question je n'utilise pas
un autre ustensile il ya des passants
tout de suite à notre candidat numéro 4
monsieur mao de clamart si on n'utilise
pas nouristan s'il a entendons nous bien
sûr le mo extensible
oui mais vous disait un autre élément
quand même il faut préciser ces trolls
un élément adhésif ou un bouchons
plastiques peut-être vous n'avez pas le
droit de choses pour choisir la règle du
jeu vous devez poser une question sur
alors un point précis mais en disant
bouchons plastiques peut-être non
monsieur je regrette je n'utilise pas un
bouchon en plastique candidat numéro 5
monsieur de repas de palémon liquide à
un élément liquide et vous penseriez à
quoi monsieur de l'eau de l'eau et bien
non monsieur vous n'avez pas trouvé non
non non candidate numéro 6 madame godard
et bien fort jean remaniement par
exemple toutes les pros dit dans votre
votre solution est intéressante madame
ça j'aimerais bien que vous alliez plus
loin un aimant que vous placeriez ou
non non pourquoi c'est un peu osé on
peut dire ça la télévision on peut
parler d mans 1 à je ne sais pas je
laisse ma dame poursuivre son
explication
ça me paraît très important le fond de
la bouteille dans le faux pourquoi pas
dans le fond de la bouteille oui et et
alors vous croyez qu'un élément dans la
bouteille la paille sera aidé par léman
non vous serez un autrement alors dans
la paille écoutez madame je tiens à vous
dire que nous utilisons nous n'utilisons
jamais des trucages qui devraient être
fabriqués par des spécialistes il s'agit
pas de trucs de magiciens ou pensez bien
que placé un aimant dans du verre dans
la bouteille ou le placer dans la paille
serait un travail de précision que
seules pourraient faire un technicien or
nos trucs reste très simple et vous
pouvez les faire chez vous eh bien je
regrette madame vous était la sixième
candidat mais sur ce truc il reste un
premier candidat de sa mort je vois pas
du tout cherchez bien peut-être
trouverez-vous le truc décontracté vous
vous ne voyez pas non peut-être que vous
utilisez par exemple qui scotche
attendent et nous n'avons pas le droit
de dire de malades à la télévision en
deux par les gants de ruban adhésif à la
jument et que je placerai ou sur un
désir est bien à l'extrémité de la
paille et ce ruban adhésif se
colleraient automatiquement au fond de
la bouteille c'est ingénieux ça mais je
vais vous avouer quelque chose le ruban
adhésif collé comme cela au dernier
moment le suffirait en aucun cas à
supporter le poids d'une bouteille de
bière
donc je regrette mademoiselle vous êtes
et charmante j'aurais bien aimé vous
faciliter les choses et vous faire
gagner
merci maman
et oui c'est notre guignol qui vous
annonce la fin de nos deux trucs notre
premier truc ayant été trouvé demain
vous en retrouverez un autre il faudra
300 francs quant à notre deuxième truc
300 francs aujourd'hui et 3 sans
fondement
ça fait 600 francs je vous souhaite une
excellente fin de soirée à tous avec une
paille et une bouteille de bière on
rentre la paille dans la bouteille de
bière et maintenant le problème c'est
d'essayer d'essayer par un simple petit
geste magique de soulever la bouteille
avec l'appareil
c'est possible mais pas grâce à un petit
génie dans la bouteille simplement un
tout petit truc âge un tour avec du
poivre
après avoir mis un peu d'eau dans un
verre d'ailleurs jusqu'au bord on
remplit bien la surface de l'eau de
boire une mince couche apparaît si on
trempe un doigt dans ce poivre le poivre
se rapproche tout doucement du doigt la
couche n'est pas rompu rajoutons encore
un peu de poivre et regardez bien ce qui
va se passer maintenant je trempe un
doigt hélas le poivre ces cartes il fuit
mon doigt
cela semble invraisemblable c'est tout à
fait contraire à ce qui doit se passer
pourquoi